what's going on guys this is rob and
let's talk about obi-wan kenobi episodes
one and two i mean this is gonna have
spoilers but i imagine by the time this
video goes out most everybody would have
seen the first two episodes anyway you
know it's it's
cool
but it's starting off a little slower
than i thought it would here's one of
the funny things about this and i think
i think in a lot of ways you're being a
little too careful
so obi-wan kenobi as a character doesn't
really need to be established and that's
one of the things that i do like they
don't really like establish who obi-wan
kenobi is and all that kind of stuff it
really just kind of picks up with this
idea that like
things are bad man
the jedi are basically all but extinct
rather aren't really any jedi left
anymore in a lot of ways for those of
you guys who ever played knights of the
old republic too it feels a lot like
that right in the aftermath of the the
jedi civil war between rev and malik
against you know the jedi themselves
it feels very similar to that right the
aftermath things are bleak there's a
kind of hopelessness that lingers in the
air i do like that tone and i like that
feeling
that being said there are some things
that go on here that just don't really
seem to matter like the whole story of
leia organa right like the whole story
of like here's what princess leia was
doing and episode number two basically
being obi-wan essentially performing a
side quest
in order to get leia it's it's i mean
it's okay but if i'm being honest and i
think a lot of people kind of feel like
this
there isn't really a whole lot to leia
that's interesting which kind of sucks
because for those of you guys who ever
read the the marvel star wars comics the
recent ones that they put out where they
basically tie into like the movies and
take place between the movies and all
that kind of stuff
one of the things they hit on is that
leia was force sensitive even though
they never really explored it never
really did anything with it there's one
point where she goes to naboo
and uh she enters into the room i think
where obi-wan kenobi had fought um
darth maul and where it was believed
that he had killed darth maul and she
actually senses the presence of darth
maul through the force but then turns
away from it and decides not to actually
become not to actually tune into the
force and awaken those four sensitive
abilities
it's not really something that they're
that it seems like they're leaning into
here which kind of makes sense since
those comics take place so long they
take place after episode four assuming
they're maintaining that continuity you
won't really see that here in the show
um but leia as a little girl it was it
was not really anything that i was
interested in i was i was never ever
really watching the star wars movies and
just kind of like i wonder what life was
like for leia when she was younger if
anything i was really wanting to see how
like luke skywalker and wedge antilles
became friends or different things along
those lines which is kind of ironic
because for this show
obi-wan kenobi spent pretty much all of
his time on tatooine you know as far as
we're aware just the existing continuity
and all that kind of stuff
and you do see tatooine for a little
while but you see luke skywalker once
and it's kind of like okay so that's
that's weird i mean i kind of get where
they're coming from there isn't a whole
lot you can do with like luke skywalker
working on you know uncle owens
evaporator farm right i mean what are
you gonna what are you gonna show them
doing right i mean there's not a whole
lot that you can do there so i i kind of
get that to a degree but even then you
know this idea of like tracking down you
know princess i'm sorry yeah princess
leia basically where she'd been captured
and so on and so forth you know it just
it seems a little unnecessary i will say
though that since we got that
i feel like they missed a fantastic
opportunity to bring in narshadow for
those of you guys who don't know what
narshadow is it's often referred to as
the smuggler's moon but it's actually a
moon that basically orbits
the home of the huts themselves and it's
like the crime place right like imagine
that like moss eisley you'll never find
a more wretched hive of scum and
villainy imagine that's like a whole
moon and that's nor shadow
one of the seediest places you could
possibly imagine instead they took her
to dwyu i think is how you pronounce it
i can't remember exactly how they
pronounce it in the show it's a planet
not a moon so it doesn't seem like it's
nor shadow but regardless you know it's
again the whole thing with with princess
leia just felt unnecessary right it felt
like they were just kind of trying to to
kill time and that kind of thing i will
say i'm a little confused is the show
about obi-wan kenobi or is it about riva
but i'm not complaining because i got to
say man riva seems pretty badass like
i'm really digging her as a character
she's certainly one of my favorites i
mean i do love the fact that what
whatever her grudge is with obi-wan
kenobi which i'm really excited to find
out whatever that grudge is man it
harbors one hell of a vendetta because
it's it's
i don't know it's if it really is a
basic motivation right because in the
show there is a point where they're like
her goal is to gain favor and literally
she says like i'm not going to kill you
obi-wan kenobi i'm going to bring you in
to uh to lord vader right darth vader's
been looking for you for a long time and
she's the one that reveals that anakin
skywalker
is basically darth vader which is a
little strange to me and we'll talk
about that here in a second but like if
it really is that basic of a motivation
that she's just vying for more power and
she suddenly just wants to bring obi-wan
kenobi in
i'm gonna be a little disappointed i
mean i understand it it falls directly
in line with sith philosophy so i can't
really be upset about it but i feel like
it would be a little bit lackluster
because i feel like she has a motivation
that's deeper than that right she has
just an anger and a hatred that's much
deeper than that um i will say they're
also just just looking at the nature of
her character and the fact that things
are a little ambiguous the fact that
like she hasn't been destroyed yet
obviously she's going to be a major
player in the show
to be quite frank having seen shows like
this before she has all the trappings of
a person who's gonna turn code and join
the light side that's really what it
looks like now whether that happens or
not i don't fully know but it looks like
that uh having said that i am really
excited about her character i mean the
fact that she killed like the grand
inquisitor right he was in this show for
like like an episode and three quarters
basically like she killed that dude then
it's just like wow and the funny thing
is knowing the sith the way i know them
just from having read star wars and so
on and so forth i don't really think
that vader's gonna care because at the
end of the day vader just cares about
results he doesn't really care how those
results are gained so long as what you
do doesn't like impede what it is he's
trying to achieve like if she had
freaked out and killed obi-wan kenobi
then yeah vader would probably kill her
right he'd probably torture her to death
and then like that would be the end of
riva but the fact that she killed a
grand inquisitor if she did that and
then brought uh brought obi-wan kenobi
to lord vader he would just be like
good job or you would say it in a way
that only lord vader can say it in
that kind of a thing but uh but he
wouldn't really care the fact that the
grand inquisitor is dead and i don't
really even think the emperor would care
right as long as the ultimate goal was
achieved if anything they would just
write the grand inquisitor off as just
being being weak and not keeping his
guard up in the face of someone like
riva who was obviously vying for his
position so they would just really
consider his death to be well deserved
but having said that one of the things
that kind of sticks with me and seems
really really strange here
is that riva knows that anakin skywalker
is darth vader and what's so crazy about
this is it's in the star wars universe
it's like one of the best kept secrets
right until the death of darth vader and
you get into the aftermath of episode
seven at least in the expanded universe
anyway
no one knew that darth vader was anakin
skywalker like no one ever really knew
that at least not that i'm aware of like
the emperor knew obviously anakin
himself knew which was always kind of
weird to to know that he knew that but
to refer to anakin as a different person
you know because i guess that's just the
person he used to be whereas he's lord
vader now right just kind of the nature
of that obviously obi-wan kenobi knows
but virtually nobody knows and it's kind
of weird that if that for riva if she
knows and she's considered the least of
all the inquisitors they would also have
to know now it could just be one of
those things because they mentioned in
the show at least obi-wan kenobi does
that the inquisitors were once jedi who
had fallen to the dark side that perhaps
they knew and they passed that
information on but at the same time most
people seem to believe anakin skywalker
was killed even if you go and you read
the incontinuity comics right now
there's a point in the darth vader
series when he goes on this mission to
find out what actually happened to padme
because he doesn't believe emperor
palpatine when palpatine says that
padme's that pate was was basically uh
killed by um by anakin skywalker right
killed by vader himself then he goes and
investigates he eventually comes across
her handmaidens and her handmaidens
believe that both anakin and padme were
killed by darth vader so
almost no one really seems to know that
vader and anakin are the same person so
i find that a little strange and even if
it is one of those things where by some
mystery she somehow knows i don't really
know how i feel about that because i
love the idea that anakin and vader
being the same person but this being
like a ridiculously well-kept secret one
that's that's so well kept that those
who learn about it would actually end up
being killed i i really love that idea
right i really love that that whole
thing again there's nothing being taken
away from the show by this right it's
not as though the show is somehow
diminished because riva knows that
anakin is darth vader but you know it's
just something that just doesn't quite
it kind of rubs me the wrong way having
said that i do love that we got to see
vader in that moment you know once once
i was about maybe a quarter of the way
through episode two i was like okay
we're not going to see vader in this
episode given everything that's
happening and how it's transpiring we're
not really going to see like darth vader
showing up in all his glory in this
episode that's not really gonna happen
if anything it'll end up just being a a
scene at the very end of the show and
then of course that turned out to be the
case
i think this is a good move i think it's
a great decision on behalf of disney in
them because if if they had if they had
shown their hand too early right if they
had if they had revealed their hand too
early it would have taken away from this
suspense because we're all kind of
waiting for that duel between anakin and
darth vader which as i understand is
supposed to happen in the show you know
i'm i'm excited to see that and i think
most everybody's excited to see that too
and kind of prolonging that and kind of
allowing things to build up seems pretty
cool but again i think a lot of that
goes back to the nature of riva and the
fact that they're focusing very heavily
on her character and presumably the the
vendetta or the grudge that she holds
against obi-wan kenobi that goes deeper
than her just trying to work her way up
the ranks of the sith to
you know maybe the second in command to
darth vader right or the first in
command of darth vader or whatever the
case happens to be right it's his right
hand so to speak again we don't fully
know what her motivations are i am
excited to find out that being said
again you know the first two episodes
like largely feel like filler episodes
it seems like a lot of stuff that
happened in this in the first two
episodes just wasn't really necessary it
felt like they were just kind of killing
time finding a reason to create six
episodes i think there are other things
they could have done in here besides
focusing on that one of the things that
i would have loved to have seen that i
thought would have been very very
fascinating here is to show us what
obi-wan kenobi was doing between the end
of episode three and this right like we
know that obi-wan kenobi took the kids
to tatooine and he dropped the kids off
and that basically seemed to be it but i
would like to have believed that there
was a little more going on to obi-wan
kenobi than that that even if we don't
necessarily see that at the very least
you know whether he was using the force
or what have you we get a glimpse into
what else was happening we get that
momentarily right like literally when
those those those clones come running in
guns blazing and just mow down everybody
right i mean you know i guess i
shouldn't laugh at that but like i mean
we kind of get that moment right and
those young links take off and it's like
we run it's like well you're gonna die
because like ob like literally anakin's
gonna come in there and kill all of you
so you know it sucks to see that you're
running run into your own death but you
know i think it would have been cool
just to try to find a way to add those
little tidbits in right to add those
little things in you know where where we
kind of get a little more about what
obi-wan kenobi was doing or a little bit
more about what was going on with the
jedi outside of that because even for me
it feels like a bit of a stretch that
obi-wan kenobi would take luke skywalker
to tatooine he would give uh princess
leia to the to the organa family and
then just totally deaden himself to the
use of the force right like i mean on a
personal level i'd be kind of curious
man
i'd be like i mean what's going on out
there you know that kind of a thing but
at the same time again this is really
more just just nitpicking and more just
personal preference but one of the other
things that i really did love about this
show is that it wasn't obi-wan kenobi
just using the force all the time they
really maintain that element of him
basically saying like i need to lay low
because the jedi are everywhere and
there's a huge bounty on us and i could
i could be like assassinated and killed
before i heard the sound that killed me
you know and so if for no other reason
than the fact that i just don't want to
die i got to keep a low profile it's one
of the things that i really think is
kind of a it sort of flies under the
radar but i think it's one of the
absolute best things about the show so
far because while while you look at the
star wars movies you kind of tend to see
jedi not necessarily as like these these
indestructible you know invincible
beings who exist out there that use this
all-encompassing godly power called the
force and it turns into like a plot
device to let them do whatever they want
to do at any particular point in time i
will say that we have this tendency to
see jedi who use the force as being
ridiculously capable in comparison to
just a normal person and rightfully so
because they are
but when you you know if you if you look
at the the video game kotor 2 right star
wars ice cream republic 2. there's a
really good point where the character
treya by the way spoiler for a 15
20 year old game there's a point where
where crea who turns out to be a sith
lord is actually talking to the exile
right the main character of the game and
she's saying that if you take the force
and lightsabers away from the jedi then
what are they right they're nothing more
than the weakest people you've ever seen
fumbling around with like a blaster or
something like that with this i think it
shows us just how capable obi-wan kenobi
is that even in utilizing the force only
really once in any real measure when he
you know keeps uh keeps leia from
falling to the ground he's still able to
pull things off right he's still able to
use espionage subterfuge it's obvious
he's a bit rusty right with his fighting
style i mean it looked a little rough
and i like how they played into it right
i mean obviously ewan mcgregor is not as
young as he was when he was doing
episodes one two and three so there's
there's the real life age factor that
goes into that he can't quite move the
same way i love that they leaned into
that where he's like it's been 10 years
i'm not the jedi i used to be you know
i'm rusty man you know and i'm not as
capable i love that they built that in
because that goes strongly towards
obi-wan kenobi and episode four and that
was one of the big things that i was
always curious about that you saw
obi-wan kenobi in episode three with
just this extravagant and albeit amazing
lightsaber duel with anakin and it's
like how do we go from that obi-wan
kenobi to like old man ben who obviously
is not fighting anywhere near the same
capacity when he faced off against vader
in episode four and so it's like how do
you how do you get to that is it really
just age like does a jedi's ability to
utilize the force really just diminish
with age or does it diminish with a lack
of use right is it like a muscle it just
atrophies after a while and what this
really looks like is the longer a jedi
goes without using the force and the
skills that it that it allows
they really do just become weaker as
time goes on they become less capable
and i loved that i love that they gave
us an obi-wan kenobi that really just
had to rely on his wits and his
capabilities his fortitudes absent any
real use of the force i think it really
showcases just how capable obi-wan
kenobi is as a character as opposed to
like he's a jedi master who can do
anything because he's got the force and
he can just jedi mind trick everybody
and call it a day and rescue princess
leia in like an hour and a half but i
mean it's it's cool to see him you know
literally use a blaster when he's
running up on what's his name the fake
jedi which was a hilarious moment um
again you know i think that this this
really showcased how awesome he is as
just a capable person more so than just
a guy who needs the force and able to
pull anything off but again nothing in
the show is bad it was not really
disappointing i i didn't walk away from
it saying like man this kind of sucks
you know it was cool and in a lot of
ways it was what i was expecting given
the disney shows that we've seen so far
mandalorian was a very slow burn boba
fett was actually it was slow to its own
detriment
you know so i expected this to be much
the same way it really seems to be the
formula that disney's following in
relation to like their their star wars
franchises i i will say i do think the
first two episodes are going to be very
divisive and i think there's going to be
a lot of people out there who absolutely
thought they were great and a lot of
people who were just like this was
boring and it sucks right i feel like
this that's really going to be where
things split but at the end of the day
like so many shows that come out now
especially when you're only talking
about six episodes right like six weeks
a month and a half i think it is
necessary to sit down and let the show
run its course and to see where the show
leads and just kind of allow us to see
it go to its conclusion because i think
in a lot of ways it could feel very much
like loki where loki was slow in a lot
of ways in the beginning there were some
action sequences but there were times
when i was in the show and i was like
okay so like where's this going you know
and then you get to like the last two
episodes and it's like holy cow right
like one division was the same way one
division just kind of snaked along for
the first two episodes lost a lot of
people and then by the time you started
getting halfway through the show you're
like okay things are kind of picking up
you get to the end you're like holy hell
right so you know i really have a
feeling that obi-wan is going to feel
much the same way so uh with that being
said guys let me know what you think
down in the comments right were you a
huge fan of it were you just kind of
like
this is it's okay you know it's a thing
that exists let me know what you guys
think thank you all for watching i will
catch you all later
peace